for decades Hollywood has derived
blockbuster drama from natural disasters
both real and imagined from the all-star
disaster movie classics of the 70s
through the effects driven spectacles of
more recent decades there's nothing
quite like the thrill of watching things
go horribly awry from the comfort of
your couch or local Cineplex in the
interest of saving you some time since
as these films remind us the clock is
indeed ticking for us all he is a look
at some disaster films that simply can't
be missed the Poseidon Adventure 2006 is
Poseidon was a regrettable remake of
1972 the Poseidon Adventure and should
be ignored
at all costs however the original about
a group of luxury liner passengers
trapped in an upside-down vessel are
slowly but surely sinking is well worth
waiting through anchored by Gene Hackman
and Shelley Winters the film presents a
gripping look at what might happen to a
group of well uh vacationers when a
tidal wave capsizes their ship and to
leave them scrambling for escape from a
watery grave
special effects of obviously evolved
since then but the patient pace and
fully realized characters are
increasingly rare among the modern crop
of blockbuster action movies I started
to believe in your promises so we are
assured the towering inferno starring
Paul Newman Steve McQueen Faye Dunaway
and Fred Astaire the towering inferno
was star-studded to say the least
the film centers on the blazing drama
that spreads after the world's tallest
building the glass tower goes up in
flames after an electrical circuit goes
haywire
during the towers dedication ceremony
the blaze leaves entire families trapped
dozens of stories above the ground and
beneath the obvious appeal of the
towering inferno survival story is a
cutting commentary on corporate greed
and the true cost of the bottom liner
alive inspired by a real-life Uruguayan
rugby team who are stranded in the
snow-capped Andes Mountains after their
small plane crashed alive at a
chillingly raw depiction of the group's
efforts to survive the accident and the
cruel climates where they were stranded
based on peers Paul reads written
account the movie spares no bit of
details about what these athletes had to
do to crawl through each day until
rescue arrived from the drawn-out
suffering of gangrene
and frostbite to their desperate
decision to nourish themselves on the
flesh of the fallen the fact that it's
based on a true story makes a cinematic
experience so that much more in settling
outbreak at a time when the spread of
communicable diseases with a growing
social concern thanks in large part to
the uncertainty surrounding AIDS
Wolfgang Petersen's outbreak a
capitalized on those fears spectacularly
damaged samasthiti same as you thanks to
its deadly virus going airborne and
remaining undetectable until symptoms
started presenting in infected patients
outbreak made everyone a potential
threat and to showcase a societal
collapse and the militaristic
governmental oppression that could so
easily unfold in the wake of such a
threat it wasn't the first or last film
to explore such a viral phenomenon but
the climate of the film's release
combined with the breadth of its
fictional diseases impact media must see
daylight the brawny action prowess of
sylvester stallone in his prime in rob
Cohen's daylight offered a spectacular
foundation the slider savior at its best
the lone star is a former EMS medic who
puts himself in harm's way to help those
who became trapped in New York's Holland
Tunnel after a group of diamond thieves
crash into a chemical waste truck
triggering an explosion it all adds up
to an action-packed race against time
and the Hudson River set in an eerie
darkness Twista this tick might be best
remembered for its giant storms and
special effects but twisters superior
acting and emotional subplots of what
made the movie such a standout sure the
dialogue can get a little silly
cow
but for the most part twister does a
terrific job of balancing human drama
like a dissolving marriage and a
character's childhood trauma against the
effects driven chaos audiences the man
from a film about tornado chasers it's
still very easy to be swept up in even
decades later Dante's Peak audiences had
their pick of magma movies in 1997 with
Dante's Peak and volcano both erupting
in quick succession at theaters but
whereas volcano threatened the entire
metropolitan area of Los Angeles Dante's
Peak benefited from a narrower focus
zooming in on a small town and letting
viewers get to know and care about his
characters additionally a peaks here
were relied on his scientific expertise
rather than sheer bravado and while
volcano leans heavily on ordinary action
movie conventions to carry the plot
along Dante's Peak offers some
unsettling creative scenes of chaos that
still hold up even now deep impact
Mimi leaders deep impact was miles above
Michael Bay's Armageddon rather than
relying on a ridiculous action thriller
fantasy of sending cowboy oil drillers
into space you know instead of actual
astronauts deep impact actually relied
on the expertise of scientists and it
shows more importantly the movie wasn't
just about showcasing the heroism of a
few astronauts but focus on the
scattered impact and personal sacrifices
I could result from impending doom in
various parts of the world there are
still some efforts that brought the rock
from colliding with earth of course but
the most memorable moments are grounded
in a smaller scale drama that holds the
sci-fi action together the wave plenty
of disaster movies have used avalanches
or tsunamis to feel the action but raw
who thought the wave stands out due to
its stunning cinematography and as main
characters intensely affecting art
nothing about the movie is particularly
groundbreaking but it's obedience the
formula is easy to forgive a thanks to
you folks visual style and a screenplay
doves driven as much by its relatable
characters as it is by the titular
catastrophe the impossible the Indian
Ocean tsunami of 2004 cost hundreds of
thousands of human lives and a leveled
coastlines in over a dozen countries any
movies are dared to dramatize this
real-life disaster would have to deal
with the story sensitively and
JME owners the impossible did just that
the film waited through the endless
misery of the story to find a glimmering
albeit somewhat controversial piece of
hope in the balan family who defied the
odds and managed to survive the storm as
with all the best disaster movies the
viewing experience can be grueling but
it pays inspiring dividends and as a
bonus check out the young spider-man
thanks for watching click the loop icon
to subscribe to our YouTube channel plus
check out all this cool stuff we know
you're lifting
[Music]